The moment has come.
This show, it's so beautiful.
I call it the See family and over
the last three and a half years
we've become so close.
We felt that we have
accomplished something
really big and exciting together
This is the last time
I'm doing a role like this,
I'm gonna give it
everything I've got.
Something's different.
The children
they have the ability to see.
Now they will come for us.
I like to have fun
and this show is unbelievable
I love being a father,
I love fighting for my family
and I love Baba just
sacrificing himself
so that they can win.
It's been a long time brother.
What made this show special is
it's a show about family,
it's a show about a father,
a mother and two children
trying to figure out their lives
in a very complicated world.
The level of imagination
is just out of this world.
Everyone that's been on this
show from props, sets, costumes
just cares about it and loves it
and works so hard
to make it special
and theres just nothing like it.
What I love about this show,
that's about people that
don't have sight is
they're heroes, and bad-guys,
and they have emotions
and they're looked at in a way
that people without sight
have never been looked at.
Our goal was to make it the
most respectful show
making sure that we change
the world of entertainment
for people who are blind
or low vision.
Fire!
Joe Strechay's
absolutely invaluable
there wouldn't be
a show without him.
He's a producer, he's blind
and he's there to further the
development of the characters
in the best way possible.
We're gonna use our ears
to listen, right?
We're not looking at him speak
we're listening to
him speak, right?
There's just so much thought
that goes into how
we build things
because we want
to be inclusive
and because we want
it to make sense.
One of my favorite
things about See
that no one knows,
but anyone whose ever
worked with me knows
is I'm a natural born thief.
Look at that.
That's gonna look
great in my trailer.
[laughs]
It was definitely the
most challenging production
There was a really great
sense of camaraderie on set
and I think everyone was just
really excited to see this
through to it's completion.
One of the best
things about playing
a character on a long-form series
like this is you get to
grow with the character.
It has truly been incredible.
It's been a very
exciting journey
going through this life 3 years
that is a really beautiful
thing about acting,
you know you create a person
and you can step into
their body for a while.
Then you sort of
let them go.
You might hate me...
but I know you
still love me.
From day 1,
we just all kind of melted
together in a way
that felt really
nice and natural
and I'm gonna miss
that the most I think.
I remember the first
time I met Jason Momoa,
he came in with such
a presence and energy.
His creativity just
blew my mind.
It's basically me being
a 6 year old boy.
Dream come true.
This kind of roll
is someone who I
was in a past life.
Living out every childhood
fantasy I ever had.
Look at that.
It's like, I want swords
and this
and this can have
knuckle knives.
I love my job.
[laughs]
During season 2,
I tore my bicep
and I had have laser surgery
just to kind of
keep my arm on.
So when I'm fighting Bautista
the whole
time it's taped on.
Look at that...
my shoulder is hanging
on by a thread.
Jason really
dedicated everything.
His body, his emotions,
and made that character
the ultimate hero,
the ultimate father,
the ultimate warrior.
[screams]
I'm gonna miss my people.
These are really our people.
And...
we created something
really special here.
You're not just my family.
You're the best that I
have ever known.
We're really good friends
and we look after each other.
The book of Baba.
Wow.
Beautiful.
We grew together and we
reinforced together
in a way that I
never experienced
with a film team before.
As a token of my appreciation.
Holy smokes.
There's your dream guitar buddy.
Look at that.
How beautiful.
-Sunshine.
Rays of light like you buddy.
Thank you so much,
Thank you so much.
We've gone through a journey
within the show
and also a journey
within the world.
You know, with everything
that's been going on
in the past 3 years,
I mean we shared it
all together, like a tribe
and so I'll miss that.
I will die before I allow
anything to happen to you.
Baba Voss,
he's awesome.
It's a character that
I can honestly say
is my favorite character
I've ever played
and I know I gave
everything to it and
I will enjoy watching it
for years to come.
I stand with Baba Voss.
♪♪
Thank you very much...
That's all I've got in me
I gave it to this, so...
I'm beat.
[laughs]
[applause]